TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We recently launched
the Poly API
to allow your application
to dynamically search
and download 3D assets at
both edit and run time.
Check out the post
linked in the description
below for screenshots and
getting started instructions.
The AIY team just announced
their next project,
the AIY Vision
Kit, an affordable,
hackable intelligent camera.
Much like the Voice Kit, our
Vision Kit is easy to assemble
and connects to a
Raspberry Pi computer.
You can get started
with the post.
Apps for the Google Assistant
are the gateway for your users
to engage with your services
through Google Home, Android
phones, iPhones,
and in the future
through every experience
where the Google Assistant is
available.
To help you learn the best
practices for this platform,
we launched a new
YouTube series.
And links to the
playlist is on the post.
The next release of Android
Things Developer Preview 6
is here, with a new
IOT launcher graphics
acceleration defaults, a command
line flashing tool, and more.
Details on the post.
If you know the basics
of building Android apps
and want to delve
deeper, take a look
at our new advanced
Android development
course built by the Google
Developers training team.
Starting today, we're
rolling out the final update
to the Android 8.1
developer preview
before the official launch
to consumers in December.
Android 8.1 adds
targeted enhancements
to the Oreo platform, including
optimizations for Android Go
and a neural networks API to
accelerate on device machine
intelligence.
Check out the post for how to
test your app with this update.
We recently eliminated
the cluster management fee
for Google Kubernetes Engine,
our managed Kubernetes service.
This makes Kubernetes
engines cluster management
available at no charge
for any sized cluster
effective immediately.
Folders in Cloud
Resource Manager
is a powerful tool to organize
and administer cloud resources.
It gives you the
flexibility to map resources
to your organizational structure
and enable more granular access
control and configuration
for those resources.
And it's now
generally available.
Take a look at the post for
more details and a video.
The 31st annual conference on
Neural Information Processing
Systems happened this week.
But don't worry
if you missed it.
This post has links to all
the papers, workshops, demos,
and more that we
presented there.
We're rolling out HTML5 playable
ads in Universal App campaigns.
So your users can quickly
spin a wheel, score a point,
or jump into level
two right from the ad.
To learn more, check out the
post linked in the description
below.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for tuning in to another
episode of The Developer Show.
To catch some of
our prior episodes,
click right over here.